in a world where cat videos and means
rule the beads one media company will
rise above the noise this is great big
story okay right that's great thank you
got it yeah that's great cool
you can still speak about that now
though what do you mean this is how I
always speak my name is red pepper I'm a
voice-over artist in the UK are voiced
hundreds of movie trailers men in black
saving the earth from the scum of the
universe Blair Witch Project
Armageddon Space Jam mr. Venus holiday
so many forget half of them to be honest
with you I started doing television
adverts animations audiobooks I'll do a
lot of video games as well and a lot of
them are sound effects of ghouls in the
background when I first started doing
movie trailers there was um that was fun
one man coming soon to a cinema near you
or sometimes I do romantic movies in a
sleepy town sometimes I'm doing horror
don't answer the door you gotta use your
voice you got to raise it sometimes and
you gotta take it to the depths very
occasionally I get recognized but
generally no but the time I do get
recognized phone goes off in the Train
guaranteed hello and people look up from
behind the newspapers the way I got into
being a voice artist was kind of strange
I used to drive trains on the London
Underground one morning I was making my
announcements all sessions to narrow my
doors a television executive was a
passenger on my train he got off of the
next stop ran up to my cab the exchange
details and the rest is history
I've had some strange experiences as a
bullet soreness I was doing a trailer
for Jurassic Park the lost world seemed
a Spielberg movie and kindly they chose
me to do the voice in the UK and
something is coming something big and as
I said that a voice in my headphones
said wow that's a great voice and I
didn't recognize it with Steven
Spielberg he was listening in from the
States into London will I swore I said
Who though is that everybody went crazy
in the studio Shh no Spielberg oh sorry
I appreciate what I do I'm still
meticulous about what I do I'm so proud
of what I do
I really don't look at it as a job I'm
having fun
it really is a cool job it's got to be
up there with one of the coolest jobs on
the planet right you got it true I'm out
of here
oh that's a wrap
[Music]